so my team was making fun of me at the
break about crying over my pug
it's a worse story than that so I bought
this pug for the kids it was a Christmas
present so it was a Christmas pup named
angel and I love Bulldogs of all kinds
anyway and so this little dog captured
all of our hearts my little boy at the
time was like 6 years old
and it was like his buddy and he's
swapping spit with this thing it sleeps
sleeps in his bed I mean this is like
the family animal right about 8 months
old its back legs quit working right
starts dragging its back legs around so
we go the dock and the dock goes got
spinal bifida we spend $2,500 you got a
10% chance that this dog will walk again
it's hurting right now it's going to
continue to hurt the rest of its life
and I'm like we can't do that that
doesn't that's not so I go home and cry
because I know I've got what I got to do
because I'm not spending $2,500 on this
dog number 1 number 2 it's not fair to
the little dog it's hurting and I'm not
gonna be selfish and I'm even not going
to be selfish in the name of my little
six year old little boy who's gonna have
his little heart broken and so you know
we make the decision that this is what's
got to happen so we call the breeder up
this oldest and the breeder was just
horrified and gave us another dog which
was very nice and so what took my little
boy over my kids and we picked out the
new he got to pick out the new dog and
he got to name the new dog because angel
was going to heaven so he names the pug
heaven so I have a pug for 12 years
named heaven so I'm out in the yard
yelling heaven the neighbors think I'm
Pentecostal or something right come here
heaven come here
you can't make this up I'm telling you
so he grew up and was okay but I end up
with a dog named heaven okay so well
there you go
but that's what happens when you have a
big heart and you cry over animals and
you love
animals and that's the whole story oh my
gosh but you know it's just leadership
you have to sometimes that you have to
be the daddy right sometimes you have to
be the mommy
and when you've you know the little
animals you cannot make an animal suffer
because you're so selfish and you're
going to spend or you can't make your
kid not be able to go to college because
you just spent ten thousand dollars on
chemo for the German Shepherd I mean and
people do this stuff and I understand
it's because you love your animals but
guys there's a point that you violate
common sense and wisdom here and if you
say I don't love animals then you did
not listen to this you didn't understand
I get it it's some of the most easy
things to be completely illogical over
completely unwise over but you've got to
be grownups we're not a bunch of
children and we have to make wise
decisions that are good for the animals
and good for the people that are
involved and you know and based on where
you are now if you're a billionaire and
you want to spend $10,000 on your dog
okay I don't care you've got the money
as long as you're not leaving the dog in
pain because you're selfish but if it
really fixes the dog and you can spend
ten grand on it and you're a billionaire
sure that's fine if you want to do that
that's okay you got to decide what
you're gonna do though and it's just
hard
admittedly it's hard it's a difficult
subject and that's why it activates so
much hate from those of you who operate
on an emotional level of four-year-old
so because you cannot process this these
decisions and without you know turning
it into hate towards me so oh well there
you go